deadly crash this morning happened up in  north las vegas these are pictures from  north las vegas police around 6 30 this  morning at craig and north fifth police  say a man in his 20's was killed after  his sedan slammed into a pickup truck  investigators believe the victim was  speeding and not wearing a seat belt no  one else was injured this afternoon  nevada highway patrol still piecing  together a deadly crash on i-15 happened  sunday morning troopers say a van with  nine people inside rolled over several  times near the charleston interchange  54-year-old gina artzer of kansas was  sadly killed several others were injured